bonsoir benoît aristide ou merci d'être
avec nous tirs de mortiers donc cet
après midi on l'a dit du domicile d'un
policier quatrième nuit consécutive
d'incidents la tension ne redescend pas
manifestement à tourcoing oui bon ça on
pensait que c'était redescendu un petit
peu puisque la nuit précédente étaient
un peu plus calme on avait eu affaire à
des événements plus plus calme que les
trois nuits précédentes avec des
individus qui étaient beaucoup plus
dispersées et moins en nombre et cet
après-midi effectivement comme vous
l'avez souligné un tir de mortier sur
effectivement l'habitation d'un
fonctionnaire de police
elle savait donc que les policiers sont
des cibles
pourquoi basse époque à tourcoing les
policiers sont son décide sur le
territoire maintenant quand on est des
cibles et qu'on est en uniforme on va
dire que quelque part ben ça fait partie
du boulot même si on n'est pas rentré
dans la police pour soi parce qu'on est
rentré dans la police pour servir les
citoyens et assurer la sécurité de tout
le monde maintenant quand on s'attaque à
domicile privé d'un frontières de police
là on est on est plus du tout dans la
même configuration
donc là ça devient notre scène plus que
gênant et ça mais ça met en jeu aussi la
famille donc l'assurance situe pareil
alors l'élément déclencheur semble être
l'interpellation de deux jeunes à moto
samedi soir mais la maire de tourcoing
avançaient la thèse de la lutte contre
les trafics de stupéfiants qui s'est
intensifiée dans la ville quelle est
l'opinion de la police ouais
effectivement on peut dire que les faits
se sont déroulés peu après
l'interpellation d'un individu
effectivement qui est tombé
en motocross alors qu'il était à l'arrêt
qui a été interpellé par la suite par
les crs s'en est suivi très rapidement
des échanges de jets de pierres et puis
dans la nuit a été agitée comme vous
l'avez vu sur les images que vous venez
de diffuser avec des tirs de mortiers
qui sont très à la mode actuellement
après je peux pas donner de noms plus
totalement faux sur le fait que ont
intensifié les trafics
enfin sur le trafic de stupéfiants on a
vraiment intensifier notre travail et il
ya eu des grosses saisies dernièrement
donc effectivement ça doigts crispés
aussi ces quartiers qui sont aussi
connus pour le trafic de stupéfiants
donc je pense que c'est c'est les deux
éléments plus le confinement qui est
maintenant très pesant qui a créé cette
pension on a entendu emmanuel macron
dire sa volonté de lutter justement
contre ce trafic de drogue
la mère des batailles at il dit il faut
s'attendre à ce que ce genre d'épisodes
qui ont lieu en ce moment à tourcoing se
reproduisent sur tout le territoire
alors que sa bataille va s'intensifier
oui c'est déjà ce qu'on constate
puisqu'il ya une sorte de comme je les
lis vos confrères il ya une sorte de
mimétisme qui et qui fait en france
actuellement on voit très bien ça a
commencé dans votre quartier en banlieue
parisienne c'était dans lyonnaise
aujourd'hui à force d'intensifier notre
travail forcément on a des jeunes qui
commencent à être tendues et puis c'est
très à la mode donc on voyait les tirs
de mortier maintenant c'est la nouvelle
mode et puis sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est à qui fera mieux donc
effectivement on peut s'attendre à ce
que ça soit dans divers quartiers mais
c'est aujourd'hui tourcoing ce sera
peut-être demain une autre ville dans le
sud de la france ou en banlieue
parisienne
c'est quelque chose qu'on connaissait et
quelques années notamment dans le
banlieue parisienne ya déjà vingt ans
c'était déjà comme ça au des cons
intervenait quand interpellé quand gêner
le trafic
il fallait s'attendre à des représailles
les nus qui suivait aujourd'hui c'est un
peu plus fréquents le ministre a en tout
cas prévu d'augmenter les effectifs de
police 117 par exemple il qu'en est il
chez vous à tourcoing on en effectif le
stable dire qu'on n'a pas eu de gain
effectif depuis la nomination de
monsieur darmanin on en effectif stable
on espère des arrivées sur l'île
agglomération puisque
chose que j'avais dit à monsieur darmana
il ya deux semaines lors de sa venue à
tourcoing et halluin
il nous manque 300 fonctionnaires sur
lille roubaix tourcoing effectivement
cédé ce manque d'effectif
au bout d'un moment ça devient pesant en
plus avec ce qui se passera avec la
crise sanitaire et des différents
clusters qu'on essuie aussi dans nos
commissariats c'est vrai que c'est
fatigant pour tous les policiers sur le
terrain actuellement et ses 300
fonctionnaires qui nous manque
on hâte de les voir arriver très
rapidement
merci beaucoup de noirs ici d'où d'avoir
été avec nous nous avoir apporté votre
témoignage en directe ur rt france